he is Rick Neuheisel CBS college
football analyst and joining us
Continental Tire Coach's Corner good
morning coach how are you Danny how are
you somewhere yep Paul Westhead paid the
price yep
all right happy LeBron is the only kind
of LeBron that the Lakers want that is
exactly right but that's the difference
in coaching in the NFL coaching in
college coach on the NBA coaching and
cutting you like you know did you ever
have a situation where you had to treat
a star player differently in college not
in college you know it's certainly when
I was with the Ravens that there was you
know Ray Lewis had two lockers right
when John Harbaugh got to the Ravens it
was the first thing you did he took away
want to raise lockers and right and Ray
had to deal with that but Ray's being a
great teammate did do it deal with it
but yeah the the pro game when they get
to a certain level keeping them happy is
is part of the answer for the coach no
question about it is that a Bama too
good right now the answer is affirmative
yes they are too good and and the
question is is that good for college
football they are light years ahead of
everybody else they are leading the way
sets to the point that what Nick Saban
does resonates through the rest of
college football's take for instance two
at Unga by llola and what's happening
with their offense you can see that Ohio
State you know went to throw on the ball
much more such the point that Haskins
through 73 passes just a couple of weeks
ago you see what Dabo Swinney did at
Clemson they went to their youngster
who's a really good player but they
realized Kelly Bryant wasn't going to
beat Alabama yes he was 16 of 37 a year
ago for 124 in the Sugar Bowl they they
said we have to do this and catch up and
I think that's also what predicated the
move in at Notre Dame with the in book
you have to have a point guard at
quarterback and those are the teams
right now that have a shot but it's it's
going to be just that it's a shot you
know
it's not something that you're going to
go toe to toe because Alabama is
formidable and then some do you look at
TOA as a pro prospect absolutely
absolutely
he's got you know you're talking about
Magic Johnson he's got that that
charisma
you know Magic Johnson was a fabulous
player in his own right but what made
Matt him magic was the personality right
the the abusiveness everybody wants to
be around him everybody wants to be part
of Showtime
that is exactly what too has done for
that up that offense everybody knows the
ball can come to them they all want to
be around him he's the only guy that you
know throws an interception and his
first throw in the second half of the
national championship game on a play
that no one was even going out for a
pass and he goes over and puts his arm
around the little general and says don't
worry about it you could only imagine
saving says I'm gonna worry about it
okay to it I'm gonna worry about it but
uh yeah he's got that kind of
personality everybody wants to be around
this kid there's no question he's a top
slot quarterback for the NFL I was
talking about this about 15 minutes ago
that Michigan could get boxed out here
if if Georgia would beat Alabama
Alabama's not dropping out of the top
four even if Michigan beats Ohio State
and like can you sort of see the music
game of musical chairs here how do you
think it's up how do you ends up with
the after the Final Four
I well III think Michigan running the
table especially as they're doing it
right with this defensive juggernaut
they're good mean they held their
they're darn good I mean they held Penn
State to under 200 yards offense they
held Michigan State to under a hundred
yards of offense after wax and Wisconsin
before that you know they've had it but
but it's interesting as you said you
mentioned Georgia because to me they're
a lot the same if they can get their
defenses going and hold that enough pass
numbers down for their quarterbacks
somewhere in that 17 to 24 number then
they're going to be really efficient on
offense as well I just did the Georgia
Kentucky game and Georgia has these two
great running backs and Swift and
Holyfield who are replacing Chubb and
Michelle from a year ago they keeping
that thing in rhythm they can give
Alabama attest but it's probably a
two-touchdown line in that game just
because Alabama is that good but I don't
see Michigan getting boxed out I I can
give
Big Ten team getting in and I think the
committee would say if it's Georgia and
Alabama in that game then that's a
playoff game that's what I think would
happen
he's Rick Neuheisel CBS college football
analyst of course a former coach and
quarterbacks coach in the NFL which
leads me to this question and I've
talked about this the last couple of
weeks I don't know if we're gonna see
these dinosaurs like Brady and Brees
rivers Roethlisberger Eli because there
are so many great quarterbacks at such a
young age
that I wonder if teams are going to
invest a hundred million dollars in
quarterbacks after five years when you
want that rookie contract and build off
of that do you do you see this wave of I
mean there's just so many quarterbacks
who are ready coming out of high school
now coach well there are and there's got
to be a place for them but they're not
going to get rid of the Brady's and the
breezes for a couple of more years
because number one they're taking such
good care of themselves
right there they're there their race
against father time is absolutely where
they're at their competitive best but
once these guys are done though in the
next five years
Eli's done been done Brees is done right
Rodgers might be done Brady's done it's
that next wave I wonder if you know
maybe Russell Wilson is a guy who you
know stays around a long time
I'm just curious that next wave of
quarterback group how long you stay with
like Joe Flacco to me is probably you
know nearing his end right now so I
don't know what happy I de Gris with
that look I'd agree with that
there there there are the savants at the
position that you just mentioned on the
front court isn't that that list that
can play for a long time because they
have the recipe you know Peyton Manning
his body failed him but he knew where to
go with the ball and he'd still be
playing if his body would have allowed
him both Brees and Brady are taking such
great care of their bodies they can keep
doing it because they have this recipe
where they know what you're doing before
you know what you're doing and they can
put a ball wherever they want to and
that is the most valuable thing of all
so if you've got somebody that can still
do that then they're you're going to pay
them the top rate but until you prove
that you can do that like
those those guys you're going to be
looking for younger guys there's no
question about it my homes and them
there's room for and it's great to see
that a guy like mahomes who played in
the air raid offense of college which
was thought to be you know just no way
would translate to the next level
you're seeing that those guys can play
as well so it's gonna be fun to watch as
the RPO continues to creep into the NFL
most important quarterback stat for you
and the NFL is one yards per attempt I I
always you know I love a high percentage
passer because I know I can trust him
when I call pass but I want the ball to
be I want you to at least foraging down
the field I don't want you to just take
and dink and dunks where I'm you're
leaving me behind it so if that yards
per attempt is over eight in the
ProLiant ranks and over nine and the
collegiate ranks now I know I got
somebody that his eyes are in the right
place they're down the field and then
coming back down to a check down so but
he's looking for that that stuff down
the field is gonna change the complexion
of a game explosive plays or the key
that I told you I just did this Kentucky
Georgia game yeah Kentucky had no
explosives I mean I think they had maybe
won the entire game you can't change the
field position you're in harm's way I
also wondered about this that USC has
Notre Dame they have UCLA I don't know
if there's a scenario where clay Hilton
is gonna lose his job but what I was
told is there's so much other things
going on behind the scenes at USC that
aren't football related you don't have a
school president like there's a lot of
things going on that they're not going
to change their coach right now but if
you get if you lose to UCLA and get
embarrassed by Notre Dame do you see a
scenario where us he does make a
coaching check well you can't get
embarrassed you know clay Helton took
the play calling back and they had over
500 yards of offense and they look good
on defense now that was against Oregon
State they're four and three in the
conference they've got two games left
Cal and UCLA they should win both if
they struggle or lose one or both of
those and fall out of the race and then
get embarrassed by Notre Dame then I
think something could happen but barring
that I think clay Helton gets another
year but he's going to have to recruit
more guy
that can play up in the front and that
goes for the entire pac-12 if you can't
get defensive linemen that can play on
par with these other juggernaut programs
out there you're playing for you're
playing for second place cuz you can't
go toe-to-toe with those fellows and
that's why you have Clemson and Alabama
they get those kids we thought Auburn
was gonna have that this year but if you
don't have that stout defensive line it
just feels like you're not going to beat
those two teams and that's what Eddowes
Ron said after the game you know Steve
Ensminger as offensive coordinator has
scored zero points against Alabama and
through tries they try to go old school
they try to go toe to toe and they get
punched in the nose and sent home they
did this can't do it you have to have
those defensive linemen there aren't
enough to go around which is why I think
college football has to look at itself
and say we have to open up the playoff
and let more teams have a chance it's
not going to change it immediately but
by more teams getting into the playoffs
I think the coveted players will see
there's more places to go than just
these couple of spots to have their
chance not only to play for the big
prizes in college football but also get
ready for the NFL gotta get to spread
the wealth a little bit otherwise it's
gonna be this way for for some time
always good to catch up with you you
make me smarter thank you Rick that's
Rick Neuheisel CBS college football
analyst mr. energy there Continental
Tire Coaches Corner
Continental Tire it is proud to be the
exclusive tire of the Dan Patrick show
no matter where you drive or what you
drive Continental designs tires for what
you do for more information visit
Continental Tire Calm Continental Tire
for what you do for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]